a climbing wall can have a flat surface
studded with hand holds that the climber
grabs or steps on or it can be what's
called rock realistic designed to look
like a natural rock wall the factory
builds the wall structure out of thick
steel bars workers weld them into frames
each frame will hold a panel that's one
portion of the wall face they reinforce
the corners of the frame with gusset
plates each frame is a distinct size and
shape to make the panels for a flat
surface climbing wall workers trace the
frames on plywood or engineered wood
particle board after spray-painting the
corresponding part code they cut out
each panel to match the wall plan they
screw a bolt in the middle of the t-nut
to protect the threads from the cement
finish they will spray onto the wood to
make a rock realistic wall they mold
cement panels to attach to the steel
frames to mix the cement they combine
ice and liquid polymer ice keeps the
cement from overheating in the mixer the
polymer is a binding agent it also makes
the cement flexible so the wall doesn't
crack or chip
while they mix the cement ingredients
they monitor the temperature with an
infrared thermometer correct temperature
is critical for the cement to properly
set they pour the cement through a sieve
to filter out large pieces then they
pump the cement into a spray gun
with slow and even strokes they shoot
the cement onto a silicon mould of a
mountain face after brushing it into the
moulds nooks and crannies they spray two
more coats this time they simultaneously
shoot a gun that chops and sprays
fiberglass string to reinforce the
cement they compress the fiberglass
reinforced cement with rollers to even
out the thickness then they embed rebar
loops rebar is a steel rod used for
reinforcing cement
they embed thick steel rods one to two
feet long along the perimeter then they
let the cement set overnight the next
day they extract the panel from the mold
they knock off jagged edges with a
mallet and check for any weak areas
caused by air pockets after drilling
numerous holes for the handhold t-nuts
they grind the edges smooth they weld
the wall panels to their corresponding
steel frame and fill gaps between panels
with cement
when they're building a flat surface
wall they spray a cement finish on the
wood then a coat of paint once the paint
dries they mount the handholds they're
made of molded polyurethane
you